Speaker 1: . Fox News host Howard KURTZ admits
he's not talking about the Dominion lawsuit
against Fox News because Fox News told him,
You're not allowed to talk about this. Now,
a lot of people are making a very, very big deal
out of this. I'm going to give you my view of
it in a moment. Howard KURTZ does like the media
watchdog show on Fox News. The show is pretty bad.
But the point here is he brings this up. Dominion
is suing Fox News over their role in promoting
conspiracy theories about Dominion voting
machines in the aftermath of the 2020 election.
Howard KURTZ and others on Fox News haven't
talked about it. Why? Howard KURTZ explains.
Speaker 2: Some of you have been asking why I'm
not covering the Dominion voting machines lawsuit
against Fox involving the unproven claims of
election fraud in 2020. And it's absolutely
a fair question. Yes, I believe I should be
covering it. It's a major media story given my
role here at FOX. But the company has decided
that as part of the organization being sued,
I can't talk about it or write about it, at
least for now. I strongly disagree with that
decision. But as an employee, I have to abide
by it. And if that changes, I'll let you know.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So many of you have pointed
out to me that Fox News is completely silent
about the fact that there is this massive lawsuit.
And the discovery led to the revelation of those
texts wherein we learned that Fox News hosts who
on air were pretending like there was merit to the
things being said by Donald Trump about the 2020
election. We're texting each other and admitting
it's all lies. It's all crazy. There's nothing
here. It's a major story and Fox News hasn't been
talking about it. Now, I have to tell you, this is
not the big shocker that some are making it out to
be. There is no doubt about the newsworthiness
of the subject matter. And I'll tell you what,
I think no matter what, Fox News hosts
wouldn't be allowed to talk about it. But
it is true that any lawyer worth anything would
tell Fox News, don't talk about this lawsuit on
the air because it can only create more problems
for you. Best case scenario, it doesn't help you,
but it doesn't hurt you. Worst case scenario,
you do what Alex Jones was doing daily on his
program while the defamation suit against him
was going on. And you just damage yourself. So.
I think no matter what, like aside from lawyers
making the suggestion, Fox News is probably
determined this isn't a good thing for us to be
talking about regardless. But there is no way
that lawyers aren't for Fox News, aren't saying do
not talk about the lawsuit on the air. So the most
you could say about, you know, someone like Howard
KURTZ is if you really disagree with it that much,
then you should leave. That's perfectly fair
thing to say. At the same time, it's expected
CNN would do the same thing. MSNBC would do
the same thing. In this situation. It would be
quite silly to be talking about the lawsuit. Alex
Jones did it and we saw how well that went for him